i want to present you a new series of
graphic novels called god's dog
god's dog is a very loose and epic
exploration of the legend of the
dog-headed warrior saint christopher one
of the most surprising and peculiar
traditions of the ancient medieval world
it was written as a screenplay by myself
and my brother metier over 10 years ago
and the story was taken up and even
recommended by script scouting agency it
was requested by several hollywood
studios but this story was of course too
big too strange too surprising for
hollywood
and so now
with all the control of its potential we
bring you this groundbreaking story the
full color is a series of graphic novels
the story is set in a token style
mythical version of the biblical world
filled with hidden codes ancient relics
angels giants dragons and populated with
fictional virgins
of mysterious monks
warrior saints
and more symbolism than you can imagine
god's dog contains all the intensity and
subtlety of our symbolic thinking the
world class layouts and artwork of court
nielsen all of this bound in a
mysterious and powerful story arc which
is available to all
from wide-eyed ten-year-olds to the most
seasoned of readers
the entire story with all its action and
complexity is already completely worked
out
and the first book
is near completion
now all we need to do is deliver it to
you
we're crowdfunding this because
it is only the first step
we've already been contacted by even
international publishers for this
but we want to knock this out of the
park so that our artists can do this
full time and deliver the oncoming books
at a regular and steady pace
under our control
i myself will personally not be taking
any profit from this first book but
rather i want to use this to build what
we need to tell this full epic with all
its cosmic proportions
so along with the graphic novel we are
also producing a crowdfunding only
add-on the secrets of god's dog source
book a beautiful volume in which you
will find my original drawings for more
than 10 years ago
an exploration of the symbolism of saint
christopher
and an exclusive text by mathieu pedro
on the symbolism of the biblical samson
this is the first thing that matthieu
has published since his groundbreaking
book the language of creation
so jump into the margins with us be part
of this shift in storytelling where the
end becomes the beginning and where the
monster carries the king
into a new world
you